to avoid dangerous climate change we're
going to need to cut emissions rapidly
that should be a pretty unconscious
statement certainly with this audience
but here's something that's slightly
more contentious it's not going to be
enough we will munch our way through our
remaining carbon budget for one and a
half degrees in a few short years and a
two degree budget in about two decades
we need to not only cut emissions
extremely rapidly we also need to take
carbon dioxide out of the atmosphere
thank you I work assessing a whole range
of these proposed techniques to see if
they can work we could use plants to
take co2 out and then store it in trees
in the soil
deep underground or in the oceans we
could build large machines so-called
artificial trees that will scrub co2
from the air for these ideas to be
feasible we need to understand whether
they can be applied at a vast scale in a
way that is safe economic and socially
acceptable all of these ideas come with
trade-offs none of them are perfect but
many have potential it's unlikely that
any one of them will solve it on its own
there is no silver bullet but
potentially together they mean form the
silver buckshot that we need to stop
climate change in its tracks I'm working
independently on one particular idea
which uses natural gas to generate
electricity in a way that takes carbon
dioxide out of the air how does that
work so the origin power process feeds
natural gas into a fuel cell about half
the chemical energy is converted into
electricity and the remainder into heat
which is used to break
limestone into lime and carbon dioxide
now at this point you're probably
thinking that I'm not it's actually
generating carbon dioxide but the key
point is all of the carbon dioxide
generated both from the fuel cell and
from the lime kilm is pure and that's
really important because it means you
can either use that carbon dioxide or
you can store it away deep underground
at low cost and then the line that you
produce can be used in industrial
processes and in being used at Scrubs
co2 out of the air overall the process
is carbon negative it removes carbon
dioxide from the air if you normally
generate electricity from natural gas
you emit about 400 grams of co2 into the
air for every kilowatt hour with this
process that figure is minus 600 at the
moment power generation is responsible
for about a quarter of all carbon
dioxide emissions hypothetically if you
replaced all power generation with this
process then you would not only
eliminate all of the emissions from
power generation but you would start
removing emissions from other sectors as
well potentially cutting sixty percent
of overall carbon emissions you could
even use the line to add it directly to
seawater to counteract ocean
acidification one of the other issues
that is caused by co2 in the atmosphere
in fact you get more bang for your buck
you absorb about twice as much carbon
dioxide when you add it to seawater
as when you use it industrially but this
is where it gets really complicated well
counteracting ocean acidification is a
good thing we don't fully understand
what the environmental consequences are
and so we need to assess whether this
treatment is actually better than the
disease that is seeking to cure we need
to put in place step by step governance
for experiments to assess this safely
and the scale
to avoid dangerous climate change we are
going to need to remove trillions and
yes that's trillions with a t trillions
of tons of carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere in the decades ahead it will
cost a few percent of GDP think defense
size expenditure lots of industrial
activity and inevitably harmful side
effects but if the scale seems enormous
it is only because of the scale of the
problem that we are seeking to solve its
enormous as well we can no longer avoid
these thorny issues we face risks
whichever way we turn a world changed by
climate change or a world change by
climate change and our efforts to
counter climate change would that it
were not so but we can no longer afford
to close our eyes block our ears and say
lalala we need to grow up and face the
consequences of our actions does talk of
climate of curing climate change
undermine the will to cut emissions this
is a real concern so we need to
emphasize the paramount importance of
reducing emissions and how speculative
these ideas are but having done so we
still need to examine them can we cure
climate change I don't know but we
certainly can't if we don't try we need
ambition without arrogance we need the
ambition to restore the atmosphere to
draw down carbon dioxide back to a level
that is compatible with a stable climate
and healthy oceans this will be an
enormous undertaking you could describe
it as a cathedral project those involved
at the outset may draft the plans and
dig the foundations but they will not
raise the spire to its full height that
tasks that privilege belongs to our
descendants none of us will see that day
but we must start in the hope that
future generations will be able to
finish the job
so do you want to change the world
I don't I do not seek to change the
world but rather keep it as it's meant
to be thank you ask you a couple of
other questions tell us a bit more about
this idea of putting lime in the ocean I
mean on the face of it it's pretty
compelling anti ocean acidification and
it absorbs more co2 you talked you
talked about we need to do an experiment
on this what would a responsible
experiment look like so I think you need
to do a series of experiments but you
need to do them just very small stage by
stage in the same way when you're trying
a new drug you wouldn't just go straight
into human trials straight off you would
do a small experiment and so the first
things to do our experiments entirely on
land in special containers away from the
environment and then once you are
confident that that can be done safely
you move to the next stage it's a not
confident you don't but step by step and
I mean who would fund such experiments
because it's their kind of impact the
whole planet at some level how how is
that why nothing is happening on this so
I think you can do small-scale
experiments in national waters and then
it's probably the requirement of
national funders to do that but
ultimately if you wanted to counter
ocean acidification in this way on a
global scale you would need to do it in
international waters and then you would
need to have an international community
working on it I mean even in national
waters you know the oceans all connected
that lime is going to get out there
people feel outraged about doing
experiments on the planet as we've heard
how how do you counter that I think you
touch on something which is really
important it's about a social licence to
operate and I think that I it may be
that it isn't possible to do but we need
to have the courage to try to move this
forward to see what we can do and to
engage openly and we need to engage with
people in a transparent way we need to
ask them beforehand and I think if we
ask them we have to be open to the
possibility that the answer will come
back no don't do it Tim thanks so much
that was really fascinating
[Applause]